[Musik]
da dort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
heute wird das urteil im betonplatten
mord von der weser erwartet drei
tatverdächtige sollen die 19 jährige
andrea k erst zur prostitution gezwungen
und sie dann wie müll in der asse
entsorgt haben
[Musik]
ende oktober 2021 findet in verden
unweit von hannover ein prozess gegen
drei angeklagte stadt die in
bestialische weise andrea k eine 19
jährige junge frau und zweifache mutter
zu tode quälten aus gier aus eifersucht
und aus menschenverachtung
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen folge von tatort
deutschland an dieser stelle möchte ich
euch den wichtigen hinweis geben dass
vieles was in den nächsten minuten in
worte gefasst wird nur schwer
erträgliche verstörende bilder im kopf
erzeugen kann
[Musik]
andrea k mit der 21 kilo schweren
betonplatte auf dem auto wuchten hier
überlegt und mir dann auch so einen
letzten schubs zu geben und sie ins
wasser fällt
die journalistin die hier spricht und
die im zuge ihrer einer halbjährigen
recherche den tatort aufsucht ist
christin war seit zehn jahren reporterin
bei bild das erste mal hört sie von dem
mordfall andrea k am 29 april 2020 im
berliner axel springer hochhaus
bildtitel damals
frau mit betonplatte an den füßen tod in
der weser entdeckt wenig später lobt die
staatsanwaltschaft eine belohnung von
5000 euro für hinweise die zur
ergreifung der täter führen aus die
ermittler müssen mehr über das umfeld
und auch zur herkunft dieser jungen frau
wissen wir auch
die 19 jährige wurde opfer eines
kaltblütigen mordens wenig später nimmt
die polizei mehrere verdächtige fest
ihnen wird am landgericht verden jetzt
der prozess gemacht und gleich soll das
urteil fallen der fall für die ermittler
ins rotlichtmilieu haupttäter soll der
40 jährige stefan k sein ein
mutmaßlicher zuhälter aus nienburg er
lebt nur knapp 20 autominuten vom tatort
entfernt dieser mordfall ist bis heute
mysteriös es gibt viele offene fragen
und bisher auch keinen vom gericht
bestätigten mörder bis heute steht nicht
hundertprozentig fest ob andrea k zu
tode gequält wurde oder ob sie später an
einer betonplatte mit stromkabeln
gefesselt vergeblich um luft ringend in
der weser ertrunken ist
wer war andrea k warum wurde sie
umgebracht und mehr über den mordfall an
andrea k herauszufinden muss ich nach
norddeutschland dort wo das leben von
andrea k auf brutalste art und weise
beendet wurde mit nur 19 jahren
kristin wahl fair zu dem ort an dem die
leiche von andrea k am 28 april 2020
gefunden wurde die stahlblauen augen der
zierlichen reporterin suchen
konzentriert einen abzweig zum
schleusenkanal in einem seitenarm der
weser nahe dem kleinen ort balke
etwa eine stunde war christin von bremen
aus bisher unterwegs
dann kommt sie an
eine unspektakuläre stahlbrücke unweit
von hier fanden binnenschiffer die stark
verweste leiche der 19-jährigen andrea k
was führte zu diesem grausigen fund und
wer steckt hinter diesem verbrechen ein
breiter weser kanal trübes wasser einige
meter tief am horizont führen weitere
brücken über diese schifffahrtsstraße
schemenhafte traktoren beackern felder
in der nebligen ferne die rekonstruktion
des tathergangs ergibt bei den
ermittlungen der polizei folgendes
in einer nacht anfang april 2020 fahren
ein oder mehrere täter mit einem pkw vom
etwa 20 minuten entfernten nienburg zu
dieser unbeleuchteten brücke am
schleusenkanal im kofferraum
transportieren sie die zweifache mutter
andrea k gefesselt und geknebelt auf
einer waschbetonplatten von 21 kilogramm
die zum fixieren der frau auf der
schweren unterlage genutzten stromkabel
sind so gebunden dass jegliche bewegung
der jungen frau eine schlinge um ihren
hals fester zieht der oder die täter
wussten ihre menschliche fracht auf das
geländer der brücke und lassen sie im
anschluss in den kanal fall
ich frage mich wenn ich hier an dem
kanal stehe
ob andrea noch gelebt hat zum zeitpunkt
als die von der brücke ins wasser
geworfen wurde und genau das ist eine
zentrale frage im gerichtsprozess gegen
die drei angeklagten zwei männer und
eine frau der im oktober 2021 sein ende
fand aber dazu später
etwa drei wochen nach dem eiskalten mord
entdeckt ein binnenschiffer die leiche
kurz darauf wird der kanal von tauchern
und mit sohn am boden nach spuren
abgesucht sie finden aber keine weiteren
hinweise während parallel eine obduktion
der jungen frau die todesursache
feststellen soll vermutlich wird diese
untersuchung nicht richtig durchgeführt
so dass nicht genau bestimmt werden kann
ob andrea k deren identität ziemlich
schnell fest steht zum tatzeitpunkt noch
lebte oder schon tot war ein gewaltiger
fehler aber wer war dieser junge frau
deren leben so mitleidlos beendet wurde
wie kann ein junges mädchen 19 jahre
zweifache mutter was muss in ihrem leben
passiert sein dass das leben was so kurz
war tatsächlich so enden muss so grausam
andrea k wuchs mit zwei älteren und
einem jüngeren bruder in der nähe von
helmstedt in niedersachsen auf die
mutter verließ die familie früh sie ging
zurück nach polen wo er sie ursprünglich
stammte
die vier kinder wachsen nun bei einem
völlig überforderten vater auf er liebt
sie zwar alle sehr kann aber keine
richtige erziehung gewährleisten und so
kommt andrea k schon in früher kindheit
ins heim
2010 holt der vater andrea dann wieder
nach hause versucht es noch einmal
andrea liebt ihn sie lässt sich sogar
ein tattoo am hals stechen ein kreuz und
den buchstaben p für papa
die diagnose blutkrebs wirft andreas
vater vollends aus der bahn er hat keine
kraft mehr für die kinder andrea k
wandelt sich zu einer frühreifen
aufmüpfigen teenagerin die die grenzen
auslotet sie trifft sich ausschließlich
mit deutlich älteren männern immer
wieder haut sie von zu hause ab hat
psychische probleme mit 14 gerät sie auf
die schiefe bahn
hängt an drogen zu nehmen marihuana
kokain
durch den drogenkonsum verändert sich
auch das wesen von andrea darstellen
auch die freunde fest und wenig später
wurde dann bei ihr auch die krankheit
festgestellt diese paradiesische zu
finden mit 16 mit andrea das erste mal
schwanger es ist ein mädchen ihre
tochter belinda mit geboren
der vater des kindes verlässt andrea sie
aber verliebt sich neu das zweite kind
wird geboren janosch aber auch der vater
von janosch enttäuscht sie und lässt die
drei sitzen und zu allem unglück stirbt
andreas vater mit 43 jahren an dem
diagnostizierten blutkrebs aber es kommt
noch schlimmer andrea hat nicht nur
ihren vater zu diesem zeitpunkt verloren
sondern auch ihre beiden kinder sie
werden an pflegefamilien gegeben 2009/10
beschließt sie dann als prostituierte zu
arbeiten weil sie es drogenabhängig und
die drogen müssen finanziert werden
wenig später verliebt sich andrea erneut
diesmal ist es diego de ihre große liebe
jedes kickboxer trägt gerne goldkettchen
und prahls mit seinem geld und
verspricht andrea auf ein sorgenfreies
leben ohne geldprobleme anfang 2020 dem
todesjahr ist andrea so emotional
abhängig von diego dass sie für ihn
anschaffen geht
andrea ist zu diesem zeitpunkt eine sehr
hübsche junge frau funkelte dunkle augen
lange brünette haare schlank und
sportlich
ihr liebhaber diego de ist ein
ungebildeter taugenichts selbst schwer
drogenabhängig aber die lesung scheint
anfangs zumindest finanziell zu
funktionieren
sie hat für die geschenke gemacht so für
uns so und das hat uns auch zum lachen
gebracht sie hat uns klamotten gekauft
weil sie sagt das hübsche brüder
bisschen so auf
kristin wahl trifft im zuge ihrer
recherche häufiger auf gregor einen
bruder von andrea er sieht seiner
schwester sehr ähnlich er hat die
gleichen funkelnden augen und die
ebenmäßigen schönen gesichtszüge die
reporterin und der bruder des opfers
haben einen ortstermin in der alten
wohnung von andrea k die wohnung in dem
mehrgeschossigen 50er jahre blog wirkt
von außen als sei sie bewohnt sie stehen
jetzt gerade von dem haus meiner
schwester gewohnt hat weiter zugelegt
[Musik]
um zu gucken ob alles ganz gut dass wir
hier bei der wohnung helfen
ja wir haben auf dem zimmer gegessen
gekocht
heute ist die wohnung noch immer
polizeilich versiegelt durch den
herausgebrochenen spionin der tür kann
man sehen dass noch alles wie gerade
erst verlassen wirkt ein kleiner
blumenstrauß liegt auf der schwelle und
post stapelt sich auf der treppe
ich finde es komisch und
die sonne sehr gut
ihr lieblingsessen spaghetti
als klamotten anzuziehen sich ständig
umzuziehen auf jeden fall
erwarten schon gute momente die ich mit
hiermit erlebt habe
[Musik]
das niedersächsische limburg eine
kreisstadt mit gerade einmal 31.000
einwohnern spielt im drama um andrea k
eine zentrale rolle
bild reporterin christine wahl ist auf
dem weg zu einem weiteren tatort einem
unscheinbaren parkplatz auf dem diego de
die große neue liebe von andrea k das
leben seiner freundin in den abgrund
stieß
es ist ein einziger tag es regnet in
strömen kein mensch ist auf der straße
und lange wassermassen bilden sich auf
den roten klinkerfassaden in der
norddeutschen provinz
für seine drogensucht und weil andrea
für ihn nicht mehr lukrativ war also
nicht mehr genug geld verdient hat hat
yego sie dann an stefan k verkauft auf
diesen besagten parkplatz auf einem
parkplatz wurde andrea k von diego de
ihrem ersten zuhälter für 2000 euro an
stefan k verkauft und das war andrea k s
todesurteil sie hatten doch nicht nur
eine wahl gehabt sie wurde einfach von
ihrem freund den sie wahrscheinlich
geliebt hat mit denen sie nichts noch
eine zukunft sich vorgestellt hat
tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich auch mit ihm vielleicht
auch hier auch keine geldsorgen zu haben
wieder ein normales leben zu führen
vielleicht auch wieder ihre kinder zu
sich zu holen das war alles ab diesem
zeitpunkt wo dieser diese dieser kauf
stattfand
zu diesem zeitpunkt war andrea k schon
schwer an paranoider schizophrenie
erkrankt
drogenmissbrauch und das leben unter
ihrem freund und zuhälter diego de
hatten diesen zustand weiter verschärft
für diego weil die noch immer sehr
hübsche andrea k aber nur noch ein klotz
am bein es war schwierig mit ihr klar zu
kommen warum nicht ein letztes mal
profit aus erschlagen und dann das weite
suchen was aber ist eine paranoide
schizophrenie
dazu hören wir professor dr borwin
bandelow
er ist psychiater an der uniklinik
göttingen
wir reden von einer paranoid
halluzinatorischen schizophrenie das
heißt dass jemand verfolgungswahn hat
und halluzinationen paranoid heißt man
fühlt sich verfolgt von geheimdiensten
nachbarn oder anderen menschen die
meistens irgend etwas böses gegen ein
vorhaben und deswegen hat man sehr große
angst und halluzinatorische kommt von
stimmen hören man hat halluzinationen
die entweder
optisch sind dass man bestimmte dinge
sieht man meistens ist es so dass man
eben akustische halluzinationen hat also
stimmen hört die auf einen einreden und
auch oft vorwürfe machen jemand der eine
schizophrenie hat der ist natürlich von
anderen menschen abhängig und in diesem
fall wohl aber es wohl noch so dass sie
drogenabhängig war und dadurch eben auch
unter druck gesetzt werden konnte ja es
wäre schon sehr erstaunlich dass jemand
der sie zufrieden ist als prostituierte
arbeiten kann dann holt man muss ja dann
freundlich sein und man muss dann auch
erkennen was der andere möchte und
darauf eingehen und wenn eine
schizophrene frau dann vielleicht an der
falschen stelle lacht oder wird sich
anfängt zu schreien oder sich verfolgt
fühlt dann wird das natürlich sehr
schwierig für die freie
und dieses problem wollte sich diego vom
hals schaffen diese abscheuliche
menschenhandel wird nach andreas tot in
einem eigenen verfahren verhandelt bild
meldet dazu am 26 22 01 21
am freitag wurde der 21 jährige diego
dts vor dem landgericht verden wegen
menschenhandels zu einer jugendstrafe
von vier jahren und drei monaten
verurteilt
die kammer ordnete für diego der mit
drogenproblemen zu kämpfen hat zudem die
unterbringung in einer
entziehungsanstalt an so der
gerichtssprecher sein komplize marc r 26
der dvd beim verkauf der frau half wurde
wegen beihilfe zum menschenhandel zu
einer bewährungsstrafe von einem jahr
und drei monaten verurteilt
richters engelke am freitag mit der
tötung der frau hatten die beiden
angeklagten nichts zu tun klar gewesen
sei ihnen aber da sie andrea k nicht in
heilende hände geben nein heilende hände
haben stefan k und seine beiden
komplizen ein mann und eine frau
wahrlich nicht im gegenteil die
investition von 2000 euro muss sich
schnellstmöglich rentieren sofort bieten
die neuen zuhälter ein pensionszimmer in
nienburg an und schalten vielsagende
anzeigen hey ich bin andrea meldet euch
wenn ich eure laune verbessern soll oder
haben nur heute in nienburg den besuch
war gegen tg tg steht in der branche für
taschengeld diese anzeigen mit
preisliste für sexuelle handlungen
inklusive sex ohne kondom gehen auf
einschlägigen portalen online
es melden sich darauf insgesamt 42
freier das scheint ein lukrativer abend
zu werden dass andrea völlig verwirrt
herum schreit ist den neuen besitzern
völlig egal andrea ist nur eines sex
machine ein werkzeug um schnelles geld
zu machen
reporterin christine wahl geht im
strömenden regen in nienburg auf
spurensuche
handeln wo es auch gästezimmer geben
soll und hier soll andrea k angeblich
für ihren neuen zuhälter stefan k ein
probewochenende gearbeitet haben diese
pension hier in nienburg ist so wichtig
weil es sozusagen die übergangsphase ist
von dem ein zuhälter so andreas 9
zuhälter und natürlich einen der
späteren haupttäter
kristin erreicht zu fuß ein von außen
sehr gepflegtes restaurant in einer
kleinen einkaufspassage
es ist nichts los auf dem ersten blick
sieht man wirklich ein einfaches
restaurant bar restaurant steakhouse
casa mexikaner an der eingangstüre auch
ein schild happy hour steht da drauf
also dass ihr gästezimmer sind oder eine
art kann jung oder hotel das ist auf dem
es tatsächlich nicht zu erkennen aber
man kann vermuten dass tatsächlich
andrea dort auf ihre freier gewartet hat
die reporterin zeigt auf einige fenster
im zweiten stock des hauses dann
verschwindet sie im restaurant von außen
durch das front fenster sieht man sie
nur mit den mitarbeitern sprechen wenig
später ist sie wieder draußen also ich
konnte mit der kellner hat und sprechen
die kellnerin war aber leider im letzten
jahr noch nicht da dann kam ein koch aus
der küche der konnte sich zwar an andrea
erinnern aber zu dem zeitpunkt
tatsächlich war das restaurant damals
geschlossen wegen der korona krise da
war nur das hotel tatsächlich offen der
chef war nicht da aber ich habe seine
telefonnummer bekommen und den werde ich
jetzt mal anrufen christine wahl nimmt
ihr smartphone zur hand schaltet den
lautsprecher ein
gutes team war mein name ich bin
journalistin aus berlin
hallo ja ich recherchiere in dem fall
andrea k sie war letztes jahr bei ihm zu
gast in ihrem hotel und ich wollte
einfach mal ein paar informationen über
sie herausfinden können sie sich noch an
die junge dame ländern haben sie das
mädchen dabei kennen gelernt haben sie
es denn gesehen an den worten
ich habe noch
der besitzer von casa mexikaner und
nicht an wen er das zimmer in diesem
besagten wochenende vierten bis fünften
april 2020 ganz regulär vermietet das
dort oben in der zweiten etage hinter
den fenstern mit den hübschen gardinen
zwangsprostitution betrieben wird kann
er nicht wissen er gibt christine wahl
die erlaubnis mit einem nachbarn
besagtes zimmer anzusehen der nachbar
begrüßt christin und beide gehen
unverzüglich in die zweite etage der
pension
das auf der rechten seite
[Applaus]
und in der nacht einen tag vorher
deshalb haben wir den raum angeguckt
einfach vorher kam irgendwelche bestellt
die frau hat beschrieben aber noch so
ein kleines kind hat ein bisschen
geschrieben mittag haben uns wieder
gesehen mit dem mexikaner mit den
betreibern und was ist da los oder
wahllos sagt er ja der die zweiten sind
wir hoch gegangen er sei schon richtig
übel aus also wie soll ich sagen wenn
einer sich streite das in essens beste
wechseln heißt oder
die bettdecke lag und
sogar auf dem fernseher und auf die wand
hanse ist das fest römer geworfen das
zimmer ist blitzblank und modern
eingerichtet hell und freundlich moderne
fotografien und ein großer
flachbildmonitor hängen an den wänden im
bad liegen sauber gefaltete handtücher
im regal der nachbar holt sein handy
raus und zeigt christin bilder vom
verwüsteten zimmer andrea camus völlig
ausgeflippt sein vielleicht fand auch
ein kampf mit einem freier statt
wie aber komplett ganze fotos und was
weiß ich alles mit
essensresten
dass ich jetzt komplett alles noch mal
neu gestrichen hier war komplett alles
dreht chinesischer katholiken
hier überall verwüstet
sogar die kabine und suchen waren alles
mit dreck
dreck ist euphemistisch gesprochen
letztlich sind überall erbrochenes und
co zu sehen wände boden gardinen alles
die verwüstung des zimmers zeigt dass
andrea alles andere als frei in ihren
entscheidungen war dass sie hier eine
zwangsprostituierte wird einfach wahllos
den männern als ware angeboten stefan k
bemerkt schnell dass es hier in dieser
pension nichts werden würde mit dem geld
verdienen zusammen mit seinen beiden
komplizen schafft er andrea k zu sich
nach hause in der garage könne man
andrea dann weiter den freien anbieten
die letzten stunden im leben der 19
jährigen beginnen
ich fahre jetzt so garage wo andrea k
vermutlich ihre letzten stunden lebens
verbracht hat es gibt nicht viele
informationen tatsächlich über diese
garage aber ich habe jetzt
herausgefunden wo sie ist
eine gut bürgerliche gegend
einfamilienhäuser sehr eng bebaut
tatsächlich
christin steigt aus und läuft ein stück
durch die einfamilienhaus gegend
mittelklasse in den auffahrten neuwagen
und langsam verwelken die blumenrabatten
[Musik]
hier rechts von mir
ist das haus steht das wird jetzt gerade
renoviert man möchte natürlich das
vergessen was in diesem haus passiert
ist beziehungsweise auch in der garage
die garage
tatsächlich hier
ein bisschen abseits von dem haus hier
in dieser kleinbürgerlichen gegend haben
stefan k seine freundin sabrina h und
ein weiterer komplize namens stefan k
ihr opfer andrea erst ins wohnhaus
gebracht und später als andrea um sich
schlug und schrie in die garage gezerrt
stefan k macht sehr laute musik an um
die schreie der verzweifelten zu
übertönen und verbot dem auch im aus
lebenden kind die garage zu betreten
andreas zustand verschlechtert sich so
dass letztlich alle drei später
angeklagten die 19-jährige bewachen er
wahllos tabletten geben und sie fesseln
obwohl alle sehen in welcher
dramatischen lage andrea ist wohl keiner
hilfe die zweifache mutter die
vergewaltigt und gefesselt vor ihnen
qualen leidet ist offenbar kein mensch
für diese monster
bekannt sind was in dieser garage
passiert ist in dieser garage wurde
andrea gefesselt geknebelt unter drogen
gesetzt
sie muss unvorstellbare schmerzen gehabt
haben sie wurde gefragt ob die garage
der todesort war oder ob sie einer wiese
ertrank das lässt sich tatsächlich noch
nicht sagen aber das wird spätestens der
letzte prozesstag ans tageslicht bringen
von diesem besuch nämlich mit dass
andrea zu dem zeitpunkt wo sie hier war
wo sie in dieser garage gequält wurde
dass ich verloren war denn sie hatte
niemanden der sich herausholt sie hatte
niemanden selbst hier in dieser
wohngegend wo die häuser wirklich sehr
eng bebaut sind wo man kaufen könnte da
kommt doch jemand wenn ich laut genug
schreien denn hilft mir jemand aber
selbst hier fand sie niemanden also der
der schöne schein wenn man hier so
durchgeht der ist trügerisch der tötungs
plan entsteht vermutlich als stefan k
klar wird dass sie mit der kranken
jungen frau kein geld verdienen werden
die 39 jährige freundin von stephan kam
sabrina ist offenbar eifersüchtig auf
die jüngere hübsche frau und schlägt
sogar vor die 19 jährige gefesselt auf
die bahngleise zu legen am ende
verabreden die drei ihre gefangenen in
die weser zu werfen
das trio entkleidet andrea und fesselt
sie mit einschnüren stromkabeln so auf
eine waschbetonplatten dass jede
bewegung ihren hals mehr und mehr
abschnürt täter haben hier ihre grausame
tat angefangen oder begonnen und haben
sie dann tatsächlich nachher in der
weser zu ende gebracht
[Musik]
andrea ist tot die leiche wird gefunden
und am 9 juli 2020 werden in nienburg
zwei männer im alter von 40 und 53
jahren sowie eine 39 jahre alte frau
festgenommen stefan k und seine
komplizen gegen alle drei werden auf
antrag der staatsanwaltschaft
haftbefehle erlassen wenig später
begleitet christin wahl die familie
andreas auf deren letzten gemeinsamen
weg sie erinnert sich
andreas beerdigung war am 24 juli 2020
ein unglaublich schöner sommertag und
viel schöner tag um jemanden tatsächlich
zu beerdigen es war sehr emotional war
es war wirklich ein sehr trauriger tag
es war eine kleine zeremonie
familienmitglieder andreas bruder und
auch freunde von andrea
gegen ging es bei der beerdigung extrem
schlecht
er hat viel geweint hat seine drehen
aber durch eine sonnenbrille einmal
verborgen gregor kniet am grab seiner
schwester nieder nur wenige sind
gekommen die meisten blicken traurig
einfach zu boden ein kranz und viele
blumen schmücken den letzten ruheort der
schwester freundin und zweifachen mutter
[Musik]
merkst du das ist seine schwester ich
will es noch nicht realisieren so aber
es ist haut mich das ist wirklich hart
und das zu spüren
[Musik]
der prozess gegen das mord trio aus
nienburg beginnt und reporterin
christine wahl ist unterwegs nach bremen
zum anwalt muster fertig er vertritt
andreas bruder gregor der als
nebenkläger auftritt die reporterin
möchte erfahren wie die beweislage ist
und was für ein urteil er sich
vorstellen kann
anwalt erdung hat den schlips gelockert
und schiebt seine brille auf der nase
wieder nach oben er blättert in dem
riesigen aktenstapel und zählt auf wir
haben nachrichten sms verläufe chat
verläuft es sprachnachrichten wir haben
teilweise von täter
videos die alt auch das geschehen halt
auch hier aufgezeigt wird und teilweise
hatten ja auch dialoge
worüber betonplatten gesprochen worden
ist war es ein geplanter markt das war
eine chaotische hinrichtung das war
grausam und ich meine das war keine
spontantat das war eine hinrichtung und
diese planung ja dieser tat entschluss
das ist ja diese skrupellose ich man
muss man sich mal vorstellen also diese
grausamkeit dass ein mensch halt erstmal
angekauft wird dann wohl wenn man sie
halt nutzen und geld also um gewinnen
daraus zu ziehen und dann wird diese
frau hat an eine betonplatte mit einem
sogenannten botnetz dort aus der sado
maso schiene wird sie gefesselt ich habe
sowas brutales
in meinem leben noch nicht erlebt hat
welches urteil würden sie sich wünschen
das muss hier im deutschen recht hat
muss gehandelt werden wie es das gesetz
vorsieht die lebenslange freiheitsstrafe
wobei ich mir sage aus dieser brutalität
dass das hier nie besonders schwere der
schuld indiziert das ist so grausam dass
man diese lebenslange freundschaft 15
jahre das nicht als ausreichend erachtet
und dann immer ein gutachter kommt er
halt überprüfen muss kann man das
verantworten
oder kann man das halt eben nicht fahren
worden parallel gelingt es christin mit
der verteidigerin des hauptangeklagten
zu sprechen katharina theuerkauf hat
sich noch nie zu andrea k geäußert und
wird auch diesmal nur knapp antworten
und so nimmt sich diese im schmucklosen
besprechungsraum der kanzlei auch nur
kurz angebunden aber freundlich zeit für
die reporterin kein einfacher fall für
niemanden die todesursache ist unbekannt
es sind diverse gutachten eingeholt
wurden natürlich haben wir ein
rechtsmediziner als sachverständigen zu
rate gezogen aber
schlussendlich konnte eine sichere
aussage dazu wie andrea ums leben
gekommen ist nicht getroffen werden das
heißt aber am ende des tages kann man
schon sagen dass es mord war ich kann
das nicht sagen ich glaube auch nicht
dass die kamera das sagen kann
da sind restzweifel aber von einem mord
kann man hier in meinen augen nicht
sprechen er hat sich ihr mandant dann zu
der tat die ihm vorgeworfen wird
geäußert
zu den inhalten des gesprächs die ich
mit meinem mandanten geführt habe keine
angaben machen
es gibt anzeichen für eine beziehungstat
aber auch klare bezüge zur illegalen
prostitution dieser mord war nicht
impulsiv oder aus einem streit heraus
spontan passiert der hass der in diesen
verbrechen deutlich wird deutet auf eine
persönliche verbindung eine geplante
hinrichtung und aus diesem grund fordert
die staatsanwaltschaft lebenslange haft
für stefan k und seine komplizen
problematisch für die anklage es ist
nicht mehr eindeutig wie und wann andrea
k ums leben kam sie wurde vorher in
einer garage gefangen gehalten dort wohl
gequält und gewürgt und
heute wird das urteil im betonplatten
mord von der weser erwartet drei
tatverdächtige sollen die 19 jährige
andrea k erst zur prostitution gezwungen
und sie dann wie müll in der asse
entsorgt haben für dieses grausame
verbrechen fordert die
staatsanwaltschaft dreimal lebenslanger
haft
[Musik]
der prozess findet in verden statt das
liegt etwa 40 autominuten von bremen
entfernt in der stadthalle die aus
infektionsschutz gründen für das urteil
im mordprozess eingerichtet wurde ist
ausreichend platz hier treffen heute das
erste mal gregor k und die mutmaßlichen
mörder seiner schwester aufeinander man
weiß wie wir schon erfahren haben nicht
wer von diesen dreien andrea k getötet
hat spannend wird heute vor allem das
urteil sein mord oder totschlag christin
berichtet live aus der stadthalle
reporterin und kamerateam machen sich
bereit im laufe des prozesses konnte
nicht klar herausgestellt werden was war
die ursache woran ist andrea k wirklich
gestorben war sie schon in der garage wo
sie von den von den tätern geknebelt
wurde gewürgt wurde und unter drogen
gesetzt wurde was da schon der
todeszeitpunkt oder ist der
todeszeitpunkt dann gewesen als sie mit
einer betonplatte tatsächlich in dem
fluss versenkt wurde und durch das
wasser in ihren lungen ertrunken ist am
montag wurden hier bereits die pds
besprochen die staatsanwaltschaft geht
hier von mord aus also lebenslange haft
für alle drei täter die nebenklage geht
sogar noch einen schritt weiter und sagt
die besondere schwere der schuld das
heißt 15 jahre und mehr haft für die
angeklagten auf der anderen seite sind
die verteidiger die verteidiger gehen
auf totschlag fordern fünf jahre haft
für den hauptangeklagten und für die
mittäter nur eine bewährungsstrafe
gregor betritt die stadthalle freunde
begleiten ihn er ist aufgeregt und
zittert am ganzen körper
er hat sein sonst sportliches outfit
gegen einen dunklen mantel und einen
rolli getauscht er wirkt ernst und sehr
erwachsen also dafür mehr rechte wurde
so ich weiß nicht was dazu eigentlich
sorgen soll so ist hier ist als martin
gerichtssaal und stehe dem wir dann halt
gegenüber
also ich hoffe auch irgendwo auf doppelt
lebenslänglich also ich weiß auf jeden
fall dass ich mich danach auf jeden fall
in therapie begeben
das ist ein fall so der wirt sich
lebenslänglich verfolgen lebenslänglich
die angeklagten werden hereingeführt sie
wirken schäbig in ihren billigen jeans
und kapuzenpullis teilnahmslos und ohne
würde ihre blicke gehen ins leere sie
schauen gregor und die anderen menschen
vor ort nicht an an händen und beinen
mit schellen fixiert schlürfen sie zu
ihren plätzen weiches leder schützt die
hre gliedmaßen vor dem stahl diesen
luxus hatte ihr opfer andrea k nicht die
kabel schnitten ihr tief ins fleisch die
presse muss nun den saal verlassen nun
heißt es auch für christin wahl warten
nach zwei stunden flammen die
scheinwerfer wieder auf die kamera läuft
und die reporterin berichtet live
das urteil wurde um 10 15 hier vorm
richter verlesen und das strafmaß ist
für alle drei angeklagten sehr sehr
unterschiedlich ausgefallen also der
haupttäter wurde zu acht jahren haft
verurteilt
mit der begründung ihm wird vorgeworfen
schwere zwangsprostitution
vergewaltigung versuchte vergewaltigung
nötigung und körperverletzung durch
unterlassung die beiden mittäter sind
jeweils zu drei jahre und neun monate
haft verurteilt worden bzw zwei jahre
und neun monate haft eine vorsätzliche
tötung hat die kammer hier
ausgeschlossen
deswegen wurde auch von einer
lebenslangen haft einfach abgesehen
aufgrund der indizienlage konnte
keinem der täter zugeordnet werden wer
andrea nun wirklich getötet hat was der
richter jedoch in seiner begründung fest
gestellt hat ist dass andrea k nicht
ertrunken ist todeszeitpunkt war die
garage aufgrund von äußerlichen
verletzungen geht die kammer hier von
erwürgen aus die enttäuschung steht
allen angehörigen und auch der
bildjournalisten ins gesicht geschrieben
aus juristischer sicht kann dieses
urteil aber nachvollzogen werden die
obduktion wir erinnern uns war
fehlerbehaftet einige indizien für mord
reichen dann nicht aus also totschlag es
heißt noch immer im zweifel für den
angeklagten
kristin schiebt sich durch die
presseleute zu gregor der am ausgang des
verhandlungssaals steht ich treffe jetzt
gregor dem bruder von andrea und ich
werde natürlich fragen wir das urteil
wahrgenommen hat denn es ist natürlich
ein sehr mildes urteil und ich kann mir
sehr gut vorstellen dass er nicht
zufrieden ist mit dem urteil wie hast du
die urteilsverkündung hatte wahrgenommen
was sind diese paar jahre gegen einen
menschenleben sage ich mal so wie es ist
so wie ich bin erstens frustriert und
zweitens ich kann das nicht ernst nehmen
bin ich ehrlich so hab ich im falschen
film wird stecke so und ich sitze
darunter neben den fersen den drei
verurteilten so und
nehmen nicht wahr
für gregor ist es extrem schwer seine
gefühle zu beherrschen er dreht sich weg
und verlässt das gebäude das ist nun das
endgültige ende dieses grausamen fall
[Musik]
an dieser stelle möchte ich danke sagen
dass er wieder dabei wart bei tatort
deutschland bis zum nächsten mal ins
kino
letzte wort in dieser folge möchte ich
allerdings gern ann-christin wahl geben
der reporterin die für uns diesen fall
so intensiv recherchiert hat alle fangen
ja mitglieder wie andrea k
zurückgelassen hat werden für ihr leben
lang unter dieser tage leiden andrea k
starb einsam
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone der bank
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
lutz neumann
redaktion bild christin war stefan
netzwerk